hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be doing an unboxing video with
co-host salamander Sally super geek box
yeah that's the right size super super
geek box there we go
this is another at all you kind of get
the idea of what's in it's called super
geek box come on Sally please do the
honors of opening the stuff for us yes
there we alright alright one item at a
time let's do this
there's a lot in there that's okay
well is so cool yeah Nintendo but what
is it exactly that's a giant [ __ ]
mousepad I don't know oh it's a Nintendo
condom for my huge dick it's a mousepad
it's a giant [ __ ] Mouse that's pretty
sweet yeah oh man people are gonna be
envious of that now your editing can be
a lot smoother and all yea smoother and
all over the oh sweet I love these
things
oh my god I'm so glad they gave you a
pac-man and not the like one of the
bloom Oreo pink red orange monster is
that he fights I got the actual star of
it that's so [ __ ] cool and to go
along with your pac-man little these are
like pixelated pixelated UB 400 these
glasses fake glasses hi there my name is
Ronald I'm here today to tell you kids
about our Lord and Savior Jesus
oh come on what's in there what's in
there all right you got a dog tags bite
me but no cool be yte me ultimate pixels
what oh I didn't even noticed that yeah
there's up things that will kill you if
you jump on them wow this this is
designed for a tiny little boy to wear
around his around this is not super geek
box should be designed for men in their
20s not little toddlers ridiculous but
no this is a cool dog tag I'll just put
it around bigger yeah she says be yte me
ha ha ha just like how I spell dick dyc
kick got the ghost in there too okay
yeah I mean as long as I get the pac-man
I'm okay now I gotta get the other three
ghosts now it's not gonna feel complete
until I get all three ghosts here that's
super geek box you better not [ __ ] it up
space invaders oh sweet I got a pac-man
one of this there's candy in here ya
hear that candy kids I'm not gonna lie
I've had the pac-man one for like a
month now I still don't know how to open
it are you serious do you know how to
open it probably I can figure it out if
you could pretty of that on ten seconds
it'll be worth our time okay which I did
really quickly ah you're clever you're a
smart one
yeah that's my can you go just cuz you
open it doesn't make it yours and Mario
and a bunch of other okay oh cool so
these are to like put on like your
iPhones in here
our computers those kind of stickers for
guitars for guitars supergeek oh alright
nobody this one stop open that that ping
is cool
there's the whole box just for the
really old game boys oh yeah
ultimate pixels people here we go
see what the shirt is service your size
I know I know oh yeah I still have one
of these actually like the actual game
boys oh sweet I could be a game boy
wherever I go then people are gonna want
to touch my buttons and move my pad
around okay
and play with my box which rhymes with
[ __ ] you know I know I did this movie
pixels okay okay it's pixel month yep
yay look at all my toys I got a shirt
shut up Sally I'm doing my thing
pac-man toy no wonder the blue ghosts
app in pixel sunglasses fake glasses dog
tag where's my space sim space invaders
arcade this is cool this is cool
and let's not forget good giant [ __ ]
Mouse one of you guys yeah there's a
referral anyway guys yeah so there's a
referral link I put in the description
box if you want to get a super geek box
and join in on the fun with people like
me and Tyrone that's right I know Tyrone
has a super geek box dude he's actually
the one who told me to get a super geek
box I think he's that room and you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out salamander Sally's channel got
a variety of stuff on there you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine you have a periscope and periscope
you're finally the first one to have a
periscope because if we get more
followers we
get pronto placement for things such as
sports clubs sports gloves are great you
know there's an obvious joke coming here
if you know I'm not coming if you know
me you know there's gonna be an obvious
joke here yada yada yada they're good
for gripping and that's right people
yes strap on this glove and you could
grip a [ __ ] like no one else's business
like a revving a motorcycle oh yeah and
then the padding feels good too you know
it actually makes it because it's like a
little rough that I kind of like that I
like a mess a little rough because I
don't know kind of kinky [ __ ] like that
a beauty's quicksand and those are real
things gloves